what's up ladies and gentlemen welcome
back for another Game of Thrones Season
eight plot leak breakdown video today I
will be taking a look at the so called
leak for season 8 episode 3 and I will
give my opinions on what I think is
possibly real or possibly fake this is
when the season starts to pick up the
pace so it's kind of a long episode
instead of wasting any more time let's
just jump right into the breakdown this
episode begins with them showing the
aftermath at the karhold episode 1 in
episode 2 ended with attacks from the
night king and according to this leak he
completely wipes out the last hearth and
the karhold
which is where the Karstarks and numbers
reside like I said in my other to
breakdown videos I think this is very
plausible the night king and his army
came south through the wall and
eastwatch-by-the-sea and if the night
king is cutting across the north to get
the Winterfell then he will most likely
pass right by the karhold and the last
hearth those are two fairly big targets
and they introduced us to the two new
characters in season 7 which were little
met umber Annalise Karstark
I think they introduced those characters
to give us some connection to them
because it will add more weight to the
situation when Anne if the night king
kills them a report did come out months
ago that said these two characters were
seen in belfast during filming of season
8 so there is a very good chance we will
see them again
even if it's briefly a handful of photos
were also leaked just a few days ago and
there were images of some of the
aftermath that is most likely the Great
War there were tons of dead bodies along
with several different shields there
were stark Mormont the Vale and Karstark
shields on the ground so there is
evidence of the Karstarks participating
in some type of battle I actually think
this part of the lake is true it might
not happen the same way this league says
it will happen but I fully believe the
karhold and/or the last hearth will be
destroyed considering they are directly
in the night Kings path I think this
will also be a way of slowing the night
King down a little bit that way Jon and
Daenerys can make it to Winterfell in
prepare before the night king gets there
it kind of makes sense to me but that's
just my opinion
speaking of Winterfell this is where the
plot league takes us next it's basically
a long scene of them showing us all the
preparations being made at the
ancestral home it says they will show us
defensive weapons being put in place
along with barrels of pitch being poured
into dugout trenches and dragonglass
weapons being strategically placed all
around the castle walls this also makes
sense and we've already seen some
evidence of this happening numerous
photos have came out that showed the
Winterfell set has been remodeled it
looks like they beefed up the castle a
bit because this will most likely be
ground zero for the Great War this is
the most famous castle in the north and
it's the one where we were introduced to
first so it only makes sense that this
would be where the big showdown takes
place the night King might even have a
connection of his own to this castle
because he is probably a stark himself
Odin and believes he was a stark named
Brandon and I tend to agree with old Dan
even though the night king and the
night's king are different characters
they are still based off of the same
person more or less everyone should also
already know the north will be heavily
supplied with dragonglass weapons just
like this leak suggests John and Davos
went to Dragonstone for this very reason
and they were given permission to mind
the island for as much dragon class as
they could possibly get so I would
assume John got more than enough for his
army there was another report that also
said the unsullied were seen filming in
the north and they all had dragonglass
spears so far this episode seems fairly
accurate one thing that I'm not sure
about is the different-colored
dragonglass
this episode said ginjury and grey worm
had new weapons made out of dragonglass
but theirs was red green and black now
there is no evidence of the television
show using different colors of
dragonglass but there is evidence in the
books of this existing Stannis Baratheon
told Sam there was different colors on
Dragonstone
I believe stain has said there was red
green and even purple dragonglass on
Dragonstone so this is bull cannon but
there is no way to know if the show will
introduce any of it or not during this
scene in Winterfell
beric Dondarrion arrives shortly after
he survived the attack at Castle black I
don't know if it'll happen under these
same circumstances but I think we will
see beric Dondarrion in Winterfell again
berrak is obviously being kept alive for
a reason and he told the hound he would
see him again so there must be something
they plan on doing what this
character there was also some evidence
of beric filming this week they have
been filming most of the scenes for this
big battle in the north and tons of
photos and videos have been coming out
and in one of those short videos there
was a man seen on set and it appeared as
if he was holding a flaming sword it's
kind of hard to see in the photo but
that is most likely beric Dondarrion
there have been a few other cast members
seen during this time as well
apparently Jaime and Brienne were here
also so this is probably the Great War
at Winterfell
this leak also says that Arya will pull
out her dagger on beric when he arrives
at Winterfell is gate but there is no
way for me to prove this does or does
not happen Aria and barrack do have a
history together
berrak was on arias list so her
confronting him like this is possible
but there is no way to know for sure the
next scene says you're on and the golden
company arrived in King's Landing and I
actually think this is wrong I think
they will arrive in King's Landing but I
think it's gonna be earlier than this
you're on already left to go get the
golden company in the season 7 finale so
I think he could be back in King's
Landing in the very first episode of
season 8 and if not then he should
arrive by the end episode 2 at the
latest they only have six episodes next
season and they will need to move things
along pretty quickly after you're on in
the commander of the golden company land
it says they have a discussion with
Cersei and she talks about her enemies
in the north like I said in my other
breakdowns there is no way for me to
know what will be said next season so I
can't confirm or deny any of the
dialogue I do know Cersei always talks
about her enemies so it's probably true
it would make sense for her to inform
the golden company about her plans back
in Winterfell brain is talking with
Tyrion Sam and the maester and this is
the scene where they told brain a try
and see who all these legendary figures
are there are stories about azor Ahai
the last hero and the prince who was
promised
so bran goes to the tree and he has
multiple visions that all point to Jon
obviously there is no way for any of us
to know what brain will see if he does
have visions again but it seems pretty
obvious that Jon is being built up into
the character that will ultimately
face-off against the night king
jon is the Song of Ice and Fire and he
has been the man trying to lead the
fight against the darkness he has also
already had
pretty epic stare downs with the night
king so there needs to be some kind of
payoff to all those tension and suspense
they are building now will brand have
more visions about Jon Snow who knows
but I do believe Sam and brain will find
some more answers together Sam did take
a bunch of things from the Citadel that
he believes could help them and now he's
teamed up with bran
so he could have him look back in time
in fact check these books I think it
would be very interesting if bran went
back and saw something about the last
hero and his meeting with the children
of the forest that could reveal what he
needs to do to stop them but until I see
some evidence of this I can't say it's
accurate after Bryan has these visions
he has them take him to speak with John
he wants to tell him the truth and John
agrees to talk but this is one Jamie
bran and several hundred men arrive at
the gate everyone already knows Jamie is
heading north so it's not too crazy to
think he will arrive in Winterfell I
know that's where I believe he's heading
and some evidence did come out this week
that says he will be involved in the big
war in the north it actually said Jaime
and Brienne were seen fighting together
side by side
there aren't any photos of this
happening but most of these reports tend
to be true I would like to see some more
proof but I am confident it will happen
but that's just my opinion I actually
did enjoy the way this leek said Jamie's
arrival will play out I thought it did a
good enough job of building tension
right before Winterfell was attacked the
dialogue could use some work but overall
I wouldn't mind it happening like this
there will definitely be some tension
when the Kingslayer shows up in the
north and it also makes sense that
Brienne and Tyrion would stick up for
Jamie because they don't want to see him
get killed John already agreed to work
with Jamie during the war which was the
whole point of them going to the dragon
pit in the first place so I don't think
Jon would allow anyone to harm him but
if it's revealed that Jamie was the one
who crippled bran that would obviously
change everything but since that report
said Jaime and Brienne were seen
fighting together then Jamie must be
granted permission to join them in the
north at least for a short period of
time I know I have said this in previous
videos but I will say it again
I don't think bran will have a problem
with Jamie bran has already accepted who
he is and
what he has become and he will probably
see Jaime's actions as his destiny
something that had to happen for brain
to play this gigantic role in the war to
come
Arya and Sansa might not be as accepting
but I ultimately think they will agree
to let Jamie live if bran says so after
all brain was the one who was the victim
so if he forgives Jamie then everyone
else might just have to deal with it
even if they don't like it when everyone
sees the size of the army of the dead
they will be willing to accept just
about anyone's help at that point the
next scene is back in King's Landing and
this is when Cersei and Euron go into
our chambers to speak in private and
they eventually have sex for the first
time then the next morning that's when
urine wakes up to discover Cersei
covered in blood because she had a
miscarriage
if these scenes do take place they will
be done indoors so it will be very hard
for someone to spoil this because most
photos come from the outdoor sets there
hasn't been any news that indicates
Cersei and Euron has sex but there was
some news about Circe's body double
getting cast it again they have used
this body double for Circe's walk of
atonement and her casting agency said
she's doing a repeat role so that most
likely means she will be nude again
there are only a few reasons why I think
they would show Cersei nude it could be
a sex scene with Joran or it could have
to do with the miscarriage but it's
really anyone's guess at this point now
that Jaime is gone
Cersei might do whatever she can to keep
your honor at her side it wouldn't be
the first time Cersei used sex to get
her way so I would say this scene has a
very good chance of happening the last
scene is the attack at Winterfell and as
Jaime is being questioned the horn blows
signaling the night Kings arrival the
first thing Jon does is tell his family
to hit the escape tunnels along with
Davos Tyrion Sam and a few others once
again there is no way to know if this
will happen but there are secret ways to
escape Winterfell back in season two
maester Luwin told this to Theon after
he had taken control of Winterfell as we
all know Theon eventually gets
surrounded by Ramsay and his men but
maester Luwin taught Theon to run he
said Winterfell had secret ways that
lead out of the castle that could take
him to safety but Theon did refuse to
use them since these tunnels were talked
about in this show
they could use them next season for when
the time comes we already know
Winterfell will be attacked there are
photos of the castle on fire and there
are photos of dead bodies laying all
over the property it's not exactly clear
who attacked the castle but there hasn't
been any evidence of Lannister or golden
company men in the north yet over 20
photos came out the other day and there
was some Greyjoy man amongst the dead
but they could be Theon's men since we
haven't seen in England sir uniforms or
golden company uniforms I have to assume
Winterfell will be attacked by the night
King I actually already said this before
season 7 even ended I know some people
thought the night king could bypass
Winterfell and go straight for King's
Landing but I never believed that would
happen Winterfell was too big of a
target to pass up plus bran stark is
there and the night King has a
connection with bran Stark I think the
Great War will end in Winterfell I
believe that's where winter will
literally fall but I know that's
debatable I also did like some of the
things the league said what happened in
this episode according to this leak it
says they will turn Winterfell into a
ring of fire they will have a moat dug
out around the whole castle and fill it
with pitch to light on fire which would
prevent any of the whites from gaining
access to the castle that's actually not
a bad idea anyone that's not fighting
could stay inside the castle and use the
tunnels in case they would happen to
lose the fight I also like the idea of
the storm being so severe that no one
could see the army coming all they could
see was blue eyes glowing through the
storm I think that actually sounds
really cool in my opinion now everything
that happens during the Battle of
Winterfell is hard to confirm the night
King burning the castle is very possible
because as we all know there are photos
of the castle on fire but all the other
little details are still up for debate
it says grey worm and tormund died
during the attack and it also says ray
Gul is hit in the wing by one of the ice
Spears there is no proof of any of this
happening but I think we can all assume
many characters are going to die during
this war they have spent extra time
building up the grey worm and missandei
relationship so maybe they are planning
to kill one of these characters they
usually build something up just to tear
it down again I would be heartbroken if
torment
but I think with this being the last
season almost any character can go
another thing that I thought was
interesting is this leaks as it revealed
that the night King still has dozens of
White Walkers I know this is something I
have always wondered because it said
that Craster had 99 sons before Gilly
gave birth to little Sam
if Craster had 99 sons I can only assume
he sacrificed all of them to the others
and if that's the case the night King
could potentially have 99 White Walkers
at the least now Sam killed one and jon
has killed two of them in Mara killed
one so technically speaking there should
be around 95 White Walkers left but we
haven't seen more than a dozen at a time
when the night King turned the baby into
a white Walker back in season four he
had 12 white Walker staining behind him
plus the one he was about the time only
a few of them have died since then so
I'm wondering how many we could actually
see next season I think it would be
awesome if there were dozens of them
these details are hard to confirm along
with all the other details about this
battle at Winterfell in the leak we know
there will be a massive battle at
Winterfell and it will probably be the
biggest battle in Game of Thrones
history but what happens during this
battle is still to be determined if any
more information comes out I will be
sure to keep you all up to date but as
of right now I can only semi confirm
what I presented today this episode was
still somewhat believable in my opinion
but these next two episodes is where
things really start to go off the rails
and get crazy if there is anything in
particular you don't agree with about
this episode please put it down in the
comment section because I would love to
hear from all of you I'm gonna start
working on the episode 4 breakdown video
tonight and I hope to see you all come
back for that one have a great day
everyone I will see you soon bye
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]